da Busco F adesiva Ah F
adesiva Allora
SC cibo a
chi
fazemos O mesmo que fizemos quando coloc
Res Esse
resico is basico
Doo
também
se pode compr s s pode
pode V
Ah
ea da
ita
mando
E
sì sì sì
CH perché non Poo siamo esercit
impossibile impossibile Allora CH
esercito esercito te
esercito dop esercito G l'esercito V do
V Eh do
v v adesso
basico
no
cam un
Ah no
cam un cam
verdad un
tempo
Cer Allora
cam
medi o cammin o respiro
E
perché fondament della nostra
vorbita
un po' che po
volare
e assunto dipend da condizione pazien
quanto tempo mand camminare pazien un po
sveglio camminare un
tempo
tempo pazienti Giovan po cammina un
minuto pazienti
Dip da Busco per
esempio
ma
spunto
[Musica]
AV ent vamos as
fotos
biochimica
mund
ases
Vamos
acho que tto
aqui tica é fixar Com
[Musica]
a
conseguir
[Musica]
Fazer Us outra
Pessoa gente V tirar as fotos aqui SIM
Alin Rela a primeira
vez a
Posi no primeiro na regi da cabea tava
com 3 graus com C Agora Agora sei se
alou
se
piorou Ou melhorou melhorou melhorou
melhorou
terminar comparar com out o resto do
zerou o resto do zerou ah Legal hein Ess
resto Esse Esse 13 Gra
a o resto antes est Bem deseado 5 Gra 3
Gra 4 gra Agora Tudo meio
zerado embaixo aqui 3 G
a regi do do pé Mas tava Assim antes
vamos comparar aqui Agora deixa Ele
abaixar olha o me olha a foto Compara a
Compara Agora Com a dela pera
aad a outra aplicativo Ele mostra Tudo
os dados até anota Tem tiar de lado
claudinho Eu tirei de lado deixa Eu s
colocar o
resultado a cmera travou a inicializar o
telefone talvez aqui olha Como que tava
anterior 3 GRA no olho Agora Zero 23 7
Agora
13 vou enviar para Eu tenho seu vou
enviar Nada Agora Agora 13 2 1 005 Bota
no Grupo pode P no Grupo SIM pode pode
P
muito mesmo é mesmo
interessante né Esse
aqui atual
atual pera S um pouquinho deixa Eu
salvar relaa
relaa Com a paciente
[Musica]
enar
anterior Pronto tiar de
lado de lado Eu fiz aquela hora Mas
vamos tentar
Agora
desculpa quer
ua
obrigado Queer àgua falsa quer obrigado
gel faz o gelo de
uaa V
equilibr é duro que Eu tirei
anterior vamos vamos saber D comparar né
D que me tirei o anterior
vaiou Agora Vai Deu Vai vai Ele tirar
da olha o meio l o marelo Tem que ser de
frente logo Prim de
frente coitado obrigado
vai ok Saiu
sai
su
prof
Pis
aqui o Dr Esse aqui é anterior
dela Em Rela a cabea Ao
pé
Agora Agora o
atual diminuiu para
13 poar os
Gal
conseguiu
alé Consi acho
que observando resto do
dia S NAS
outras Eu saio toda
Outro
lado controlada o Ideal é ter um
pedestal e fixar o celular outra né Esse
Mas o las a gente Bota na mesa é o laser
é Mas Esse sistema Meu é bom ter um um
pedestal
pedestal tripé tripé Eu tenho
l comecando do comeo di nu Nuo una
colonna una
colonna non
non stava Coné
ST Mas ninguém de me Fez Uma pergunta
ninguém de V me Fez Uma
pergunta a pergunta ém é ninguém a
pergunta é Tem duas mudas o b e o t por
que Pens o deser do B do T é do
T Porque o t no É
genético é Isso Eu Achei que fosse
Alatri pegou O primeiro que pegou a né
tinha perguntar por causa disso sabe que
falei nada fado é perché esercito non
esempio
perché perché
se
intendesse intendesse intendesse
echion
rapida
e mio ma io biochimica non
te quello che esercito
B Endo Vabbè una una manovra
e Esercito esercito
beor
perch bus mutan è ben
evid
esercito Ess
miglioramento non T intenso con te non
sa
hierarch e
f por Iso SAP era migliorata o segreto
é piav Agora ma
smut con no be be te nonè mai smut sta
te conteni allora per esempio non tendi
SM
Cont
content un poco aumenta un poco
eh eh po SC
eh5
scriv perché aumentò Perché serto è
S eh
poro
muito m
Nada gosto de ver
contens da capea R da
capeo anota coluna né tinha Tera perché
la seconda
già
dato la Tera St pronta
uhum aumentou né uhum 50 Gra a Noa
é desbloqueio desbloqueio muito quer
trando Uma
pergunta usou o b SIM SIM t o b a Como
dela Deu o b e o t Eu poderia usar o t
Porque Ele ia dar queis a mesmo por
curiosidade iia usar o t masoria OB Esse
result ent Isso queria saber posso Posso
Us ir l voltar Fazer
Tudo
per tempo per tempo Sen Vai
consa
qu
cons
cer
speg Perché
Perché
st
Ma
Perché m compleo voci da Confusion Seo
solo che primo testi
che consulta no consulta è esempio busc
e sa che cibo è se alimentare tossic
allergia falta di acqua carenza de
nutrienti Eh E che ma non perché sennò
ci dà una confusione che
[Musica]
quando liberou algumas e outras liberou
signific perch ha ciato una cos e
[Musica]
cos
Noli non la
che non sai perch non sai
che miglior sì
miglior non è important
important un
miglioramento
Nona geral O que Ele precisava
equilibrar Ele equilibr e O que
precisava vai equilibrar de outras
outras coisas Menor por exemplo tipo
camadas Tem pador
pador Ess pador sumir Ou baiar diminuir
diminuir é Tem sabemos é Porque Tem
coisas que é Como se fosse Uma limpeza
de Uma casa né Tem coisas que descar a
cebola viu descansando a cebola
acontecendo no na limpeza geral limpa
Tudo Mas
minuciosamente a Agora as coisas menores
que Ela Tem Cada vez que Ele for Fazer o
Testo Vai pode ser que aparea outra
coisa a Ele Vai limpar outra coisa vai
usar Outro
reset Tem
o problema que
Doo do
important
intellia Prim Iso
e
[Musica]
Iso acord
necess sei mais Ou menos que pode é
Porque os exames dela os timos estavam
Bons Mas Fez Fez alimentar toxica Cois
Fe
ua falta
di non
sient
no fare
[Musica]
fando
allistic
No la Ponci
Ponci cam al cam
volt pronto
Un o bene non po' gesta perché stci
ugualmente Eh
perché certezza sta funzionando per
conteni fico Cont non funzionare solo se
non funzionava er la postura Eh forza
boh
Eh
sì
te
[Musica]
Sì
ecologico
all sempre
per
serv
perché
non
terreno bloc tereno da
bloc
FR
Paradise e do Infatti S schema
eh
scher detto scher
in
sìììì lato No no no
inclin
fa
Boh non fa lingua qu perché las che non
mutato no che la lingua mai è
strutturato
problemo SP tempo con la lingua che Cont
E
no
perché una una fraghez poi c se non sei
Non sapendo
test
pronta contatto S
forte
forte la muscolo
forte forte B
bassoa lavolo un bloc Sen è
CPA pronta in contatto e or
sciato impur
ahur
ah è perché sta in
con Sens mesmo
mesma se esemplo facendo un test Us te a
te
Eh guarda che no St a certezza Sì sì lo
diagnostico se volta forte eh usato m a
te Pronta Pronta impur
impur
impur sopr
dicic pronta
impur forza Muda
te impura bom
timado Mas a quando anou o bioo liberou
o ne do pcoo aqui por
Porque deten Os mcos da da
cervical por deten mcos da cervical por
acontece Isso
Pora que torion
também
Sens perché per esempio
se affettare un organo centr che
intestino
sentr
schema osserv
schem non sta una
causa solo osserv
Cont
che
e se biochimica e terreno
conten St contenendo che
FR un
problema non pere perché Sol 15 minut
che è stato un problema
però
problema eh
fig aqui F maiso no
caso mudou a postura mudou a postura
mudou a postura AA é perfe por
isur na ver é B é é B B pode F Assim
Dear o Outro Vai
tirar
deixa se deixa
sems entenderam Aqui deixa O que botou e
Bota mais um entendeu hum mais um Ah
continua que SIM vou girar o b limpeza
limpou Uma parte da
casao
descar a Isso Eu queria saber aquela
pergunta FOI baseada Em cima disso Como
dela Deu B e t Ou Eu posso Fazer acho
que explique
direito
Endo Agora SIM
Uma pancas 21o pancas 21 Bom e a Vai vai
Com a m direita l Com a m esquerda ir
Com a esquerda difil e Outro punto é vin
que aqui clavicola
Prim
clavicola aqui perto da primea Costel
pero T sego Tess alergia Allora faz
Assim D Pega orelhas os Dois aqui Pega
Sem Sem empurrar sem puxar Pega S
Toca Desena os dentes fecha o olho fecha
os ol pronta
impur
alergia
tossica Tox Point do do Martin um do
aqui osso zicom
daoo
zicom da Basso zoma eh tocca sempre
eh abaixo abaixo abaixo
baixo aqui é Tox
alimentar Isso é intoxica intoxica geral
de remédios
de qual
intoxica
Ponto P
falta faz de faz Pega os cabelos Semar
Pega Ass aqui aqui aqui aqui aqui S Pega
no cabelo s s Pega Pega Pega
cabelos
Pega
pegi CAB Ass Assim Maria chiquinha Maria
chiquinha aperta cabab uhum mesmo
assunto forte problema abente
frago quer jeito n pronta Ah vai dar Ah
falta de ua falta
deua falta de
Aga SAP falta de Aga Oi SAP que falta de
Aga s d um de
agao
deber
put difc Beber ua a minha secreta P um
copinho que Beber
Beber
Uber
u é Uma inveja que aqui
deit S um pouquinho de
u Beber fazem Assim senta é muito
senta Pega D Por favor ad eu mesmo
ANC una persona chea
scello
pron B funziona è falta
di se falta
diora test Vai SC test Se
verd
pronta
medio da falta di
verd verd che falta
di se
apaga un poco di Aqua
ehao
No
perché
is é problema
doa
aliment Eu
mesmo que usar S Como
test
Olmi
stato perch
è
problema è è
importante F importante intolleranza è
forte per